Now I'll actually talk about one specific form of an edge detector.
Perhaps the most widely used edge detector out there,
referred to as the Canny edge detector.
You start off by filtering the image with a derivative of a Gaussian.
Remember, the whole concept of, actually, you can actually just
apply the Gaussian to the derivative operator and generate a new kernel.
And that's what this process is about.
Basically, we would actually filter the image with a derivative of a Gaussian.
And that will give us a magnitude and orientation of the gradient.
So this is my original image.
These are the two derivatives in x and y.
Again, just for showcasing purposes, I'm showing you some results.
They are not the actual outputs all of this using this process, but
I want to make sure that you guys understand what's going on here more
rather than actually giving you the actual outputs.
This is, of course, the magnitude of the gradient.
And, of course, the, the angle, the orientation of the gradient everywhere.
We've looked at how to compute all of this so far.
So these are the first two steps.
The third step of computing edges is, again,
taking this magnitude and doing some local processing to enhance the edges.
So in Canny edge detector, what basically is done is non-maximum suppression.
Which basically is all about thinning the multiple pixels.
So there are lots of pixels, for example, here you see right next to each other.
And taking these into a single pixel width line.
So anywhere where I see a lot of these types of regions that seem to have more
than one pixel, we want to kind of start combining them into single pixels and
lines of single pixels.
These are, again, approximations to kind of look at what's going on.
But basically, in essence, it comes down to, just take the wide ridges,
remember those ridges from the way we've looked at a height map of
these types of things, and reduce them down to something that's one pixel width.
The fourth step in Canny edge detector is taking the gradient image again and
coming with a method of both linking and
thresholding pixel groupings from one level to the other.
So in essence, what we do is, anywhere out there we would define two thresholds.
These two thresholds would be the low value and the high value.
And then use the high threshold to start an edge.
So wherever there's a high value information.
again, this is just for demonstration purposes.
I would, let's say find the high value here.
I would start the curve at this thing.
And basically, anywhere in the thing wherever I find low values,
I'll continue finding the curve.
So using this kind of a technique,
we can actually start kind of building more local edges out of it.
Doing this process and kind of doing various types of filtering mechanisms to
keep on enhancing them within the thresholding that's going on,
we should be able to generate a edge map.
So here you see now a complete edge map.
All of the edges are one pixel.
Sometimes they form complete lines out of it.
Of course, this is still an image, and these are not line segments per se, but
then there are other methods that can be used to actually combine these into
line segments, you know, Hough transform methods and
stuff that you can read about on your own.
And we will not cover them.
We will actually come back at looking these types these types of edges for
some other work in a later lecture.
This, of course, is the actual output of edges of the original tiger image that
we were looking at.
Just to reiterate, these were the steps we went through.
We filtered the image using a derivative for Gaussian,
found the gradient information, did non-maximum suppression to find the ridges,
down to single pixels, then once we took these single pixels,
we started linking and thresholding the images, or, the the edges.
We're basically looking at the low and high and use the high threshold to
start edge curves and the low ones to continue it to get an output like this.